henri emmanuelli maintenant on va faire
un exercice un petit peu compliqué
souvent les hommes politiques qui
arrivent mieux que les autres chez pas
pourquoi ça s'appelle l'interview
mensonges et ont peu bougé vent le
jingle que la vision n'ont pas bougé
mais ce soir exceptionnellement comme
l'abbé prévost on était sûr de pas
arrivé à le tenir donc on a changé la
règle du jeu tout à l'heure je vais lui
faire avaler un bouquin way a volontiers
oui ça fait six fois qu il y près
monsieur prévost alors que je dis
monsieur prévost je suis marqué bien
aller attention pas de violence si vous
henri emmanuelli donc vous mentez 1
est ce que ça vous choque que des gens
qui ont bénéficié de l'école en france
des soins dans les hôpitaux
dès qu'il gagne un peu d'argent il
quitte la france pour aller vivre en
angleterre et payer leurs impôts en
angleterre ça ne me choque pas est ce
que vous comprenez que des gens qui
travaillent dans le froid avec des
masses dans des usines de poissons
surgelés demande à travailler 35 heures
vous trouvez ça normal vous non je
trouve pas ça normal
est ce que vous êtes choqué par le fait
par exemple que la compagnie
d'assurances axa double les primes
d'assurance pour les handicapés à la
raison à la région
total qui utilisent des bateaux pourri
mais pas cher le business après tout ils
font déjà faire quoi pour deux affaires
sont dans leur job
vous êtes d'accord vous que les prêts
dans les bibliothèques municipales
soient payants absolument
ces chercheurs auteurs que
deviendrait-il autrement pas grave qui
soit pas lui pourvu qu'ils soient bien
payés c'est scandaleux quand même que
vous trouvez pas non que les musées soit
gratuit parce que finalement c'est le
contribuable qui paye et puis je trouve
ça permet pas aux gens d'apprécier à
leur juste valeur les étapes que les
tableaux qu'on leur montrait faut quand
même donner un peu de soi même n'est ce
pas serait pas que fabius est un peu
trop à gauche quand même si
à part ça on va passer aux femmes
oui plus facile vous êtes atteint par le
démon de midi
oui oui c'est l'interview mansart jb oui
oui vous êtes toujours d'un club
échangiste
oui j'avais puisque alors est ce que
vous savez que deux plus deux à
déménager ou j'ai puisé dans le temps du
boulevard edgar quinet maintenu parce
qu'on est le boulevard je connais pas
traîné mais je trouverais quand même
vous êtes quand vous voulez vous avez de
quoi rouler à un pétard évidemment
pétards en début de soirée après je
passe à autre chose comme a les mains
mais soyez vous aviez arrêté la cocaïne
et les mâles unis